welcome back to the rich 20 this is how
it will be when we win the AFC a seat
just like that
86 yards that is fantastic
it sure is no question about that what a
call by Jim Donovan last night and
joining us right here is the man of the
hour Damon Shaheed Giuseppe from Browns
camp congratulations on that big moment
thank you so much thank you rich
appreciate the phone call thank you so
much so let's walk through here your
your your journey folks who may not know
how did you try out for the Browns Damon
I talked to the Browns one whom I was
playing flag football and somebody told
me how they they made a way to the levy
and he just gave me a contact number and
I was talking to this guy for about a
couple months and he just told me about
there was a child in the Browns and I
wasn't sure if it was really not because
I've never met the guy but I said I'm
gonna give it a shot and just call my
mom and ask her she gave me a flight out
there and she was able to use all our
points to give me a flight out there and
I just showed up to the to the child
took a flight stayed out there shuttle
to the Charter and was able to put my
name on a list try out you put on your
name on the list because you made it and
knowing that you knew alonzo highsmith
of the Browns and you didn't write that
fact list printed out in ink and
everything and I was please let me down
I talk too long so you know I might be
here and then he got which a man named
the pen at the bottom and then he let me
try and they were wrong as I walked in
that's a real straight to you damn did
you ran for three eight as well and then
much has been made about your living
situation between that try
in the ability for you to go to Berea
and do it there walk me through that
please so like when I got to Florida out
of money left and so I stand at the
airport for like two three hours and I
was trying to get a shuttle to take me
as close as I could to a venturi mall
and I was sitting there for like three
hours and someone's like you didn't take
the bus and I was like no I don't have
any point to take the bus you got and
then he ended up give me five dollars
and I took the County bus always to
Aventura Mall and ended up just walking
around I would turn boil until nighttime
and then nighttime came and I walked
straight to the facility and slip out
there and tell a child a toy and then
did you sleep on the beach did I read
that Damon you slept on the beach the
first time I was up on the grass right
outside the security make sure I did
this child and then in a day time I went
to the beach and I saw the sweep and
then and then I'll just walk around I
walked to the beach to the bar and I
just walk around all day and then I'll
go back to sleep outside of security so
I can work out again in the morning and
then you get to Berea and you wind up
getting a contract and so last night was
the first punt you received in a live
game since 2016 and then you took it is
that it and you took it to the house it
was a blessing to be able to go back
there another superstar because my first
time in a couple years and it was just
all right when I seen a kick and I was
super excited to be able to get back
there and just return equip and whose
shoes were you wearing last night you
know I go there right now
you know I shoes off its feet in here
you can wear mine I broke them and
everything is just for you these gonna
feel good shoes and then the whole team
pig piles on top of you did you call
your mom last night yeah I talked to my
mom I talked to my mom last night touch
my father I talked to my whole family my
mom was so excited and she was blessed
he says he started crying and you know
my mother issues we just trying to get
better and she was super happy for me
unfortunately I've got the end of the
hour of my radio show coming up so I've
got only a minute left with you what
does it feel like right now
with your journal came a long way you
know the super size I just want to get
better I can edit it just try to get
that every day and just work hard so it
just feels like a blessing like a dream
come true like just thinking about this
for years and not an opportunity to do
it and what do you tell people who might
were being told that they can't in
whatever profession they're doing right
now oh I tell them a keyboard I tell
them just keep working hard and it's
your dream like you control each other's
going out in the world you can't meet
there's no nothing in the world you
can't do and I just found just keep
pushing even when it doesn't seem right
you know I'm saying you make your own
destiny you could do whatever you want
in this life you didn't give the shoes
back to Odell did you you hold on oh um
Damon hey congratulations on that big
big run back and hopefully it's not the
last for you thank you so much you got
it thanks for the call that's Damon she
Giuseppe water story at Damon oh one
five on Twitter for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app